[Musique]
monsieur hamilton tu aimes ce que tu
vois
peter
pourquoi est ce que quelqu'un voudrait
que tu ne sois plus en vite qu est ce
que tu pars code administratif 8,4 de
2,7 confirmé cible neutraliser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que tu es attaché à 20 moi je
dis qu'elle peut nous compromettre nos
repas elle cette fille c'est la
meilleure c'est moi qui les recrute et
forme et déparle incessibles merde
enfin j'ai pas réussite et je te le
promets que tu vas bientôt tirer jeune
fille mais l'administration veut être
particulièrement présente dorénavant
fait quelque chose de mal
ils ne m'auraient pas envoyer autrement
[Musique]
qui est responsable la compagnie avait
rien à voir là dedans tu crois pas à ce
look n'arrête pas d'enfreindre le
protocole je t'ai demandé en mariage et
a disparu sans même me donner
d'explications
elle a toujours été la préférée de doc
elle représente un réel danger pour
l'accompagnement je veux avoir un
morceau de cette fille
dis-lui que ça peut être une dans un
doigt peu importe
t'avais prévenu je serais peut-être pas
capable de protéger une deuxième fois
[Musique]
tu dois annuler l'ordre d'exécution tu
sais que je peux pas faire ça c'est les
affaires
c'est un beau matin pour saab
[Musique]
mais que les gardes de sécurité ma
famille en alerte
[Musique]